[Music]
what if you could walk into a pharmacy
and get meds that could actually treat
covet 19
not just the symptoms that's not an
option right now but we're one step
closer
a pharmaceutical company called merck
has been developing a pill that people
who have kova 19 could take it home
without having to go to the hospital
mark is applying for fda authorization
which could come by the end of the year
if it gets authorized by the u.s food
and drug administration it could be a
game changer
so what is this new pill and why might
it be a turning point in the fight
against covet i'm in the office doing
some digging on the topic
[Music]
up until now the main therapies for
kobit 19 like monoclonal antibodies have
all required an iv but this new
medication doesn't
patients could get a prescription from
the doctor and get that filled at their
local drugstore the same way we do for
flu or other diseases
it's called molna pirivir when someone
is diagnosed with covid or when they
have you know clear symptoms of covid
um there aren't a lot of options for
them doctors would have something to
give
patients right away to prescribe to them
that's my co-worker and fellow amherst
college alum betsy mckay
she's been covering mona piravir for
more than a year including when
promising preliminary results were first
reported in the spring and she says this
pill is a huge deal
that's because now for the first time
ever you can potentially treat covet 19
orally similar to how you take ibuprofen
but instead of taking it just once to
fend off body aches you'd take four
pills twice a day for five days
here's how it works
the goal is to stop the coronavirus from
multiplying inside your cells molna
pirovir does that by messing up the
virus's ability to make copies of itself
which prevents you from getting sick
enough that you might need to go to the
hospital it does that by basically
acting as a wrench in the virus's
replication assembly line once the virus
infects the cell it uses the cell's
machinery to copy its genetic
information over and over again that rna
contains the instructions for building
viruses that can infect and spread as
the virus copies itself molna piravir
inserts itself into these instructions
if the language isn't quite right the
message gets lost in translation new
virus particles don't form correctly and
they can't continue spreading and
infecting
good for you
bad for the virus that's why it's called
an antiviral it's similar to other
antivirals including remdezavir which is
given to covet patients through an
infusion and tamiflu which you can get
through a prescription to treat the flu
in a clinical trial the pill treatment
cut the risk of hospitalization or death
by about half when people with mild to
moderate covet took it within five days
of showing symptoms and no one died
antivirals worked best when given early
that was the problem with other covet
treatments that required an iv
by the time patients got them they were
already in the hospital
molna piravir worked so well that merck
stopped enrolling new patients in the
study after discussions with the fda to
get ready to distribute it quickly merck
has been manufacturing courses of
treatment pills already and has said it
will have 10 million ready by the end of
the year so by the end of the year
hopefully people could start getting
this drug
betsy called it a tamiflu for cobin it
would help prevent you from getting
really sick
it's also important in that it will help
reduce the amount of virus that is
spreading in the community right if
people are treated
right away
once they're infected
cuts the amount of virus in their body
and they stop spreading it it will be a
really really important tool to have
for now the drug has only been tested in
unvaccinated patients who are high risk
for covet complications but betsy said
the hope is that it works on everyone
including people who are vaccinated
because molna pyrivir disrupts a process
that's common to other rna viruses like
influenza mers and sars in theory it
could be useful to treat those too i
asked betsy if there were any concerns
she said one concern was that the side
effects of the pill are unclear merck
has released limited information about
side effects but said that drug was safe
some doctors have also expressed concern
that the way it works could also disrupt
the way our own cells work that's
because rna is important in human cells
too you have to be sure that it's
messing with the virus but not the human
cell merck said it has tested it
extensively and hasn't found that
problem
with this drug the other thing to
remember is that people would take it
for five days not an extended period
but that is one reason that um doctors
have questions about it and want to see
more data another concern
doctors are worried that having
monopyravir available could discourage
people from getting vaccinated they're
worried that people will think of this
as a replacement for vaccination but
public health experts say it's not and
neither are other similar cova drugs
that are in the pipeline an easy to take
treatment like mono piravir makes the
disease more manageable but it has to be
said that
there are people who
um took this drug in the clinical trial
and still ended up in the hospital
so
you know it's
it's not a cure-all for everybody
public health experts say that it's
better to prevent covet than treat it
that's why getting vaccinated is still
the best way to put the pandemic behind
us
if you have any questions about covid
please leave them in the comments and if
you're interested in infectious disease
or public health i've left some links to
betsy's work down below and don't forget
to hit subscribe so you get your dose of
science and health updates hasta luego
nos vemos prontos
[Music]